hey everyone it's Sarah the registered
nurse rn.com and in this video I'm going
to be going over the macro lines so
let's get started the macrolides are a
group of antibiotics that mainly Target
gram-positive bacteria but they can go
after some gram negative as well so with
gram positive what they like to go after
are like streptococcal infections
carnivacterium diphtheriai which is a
main cause of diphtheria and
staphylococcal infections now one group
that the macrolides aren't effective
against that are also gram-positive are
the interococcal infections so whenever
we're talking about gram-negative they
like to Target salmonella chlamydia and
gonorrhea which are big sexually
transmitted infections and some stomach
infections that are caused by
helicopactor pylori and hemophilus
influenzae which is something that
affects younger children and can lead to
epiglottitis now because the microlides
target these certain things they're
really good at treating certain cases of
ear infections especially ones that
affect the middle ear also sexually
transmitted infections as you've seen
with chlamydia and gonorrhea and
infections that invade the respiratory
system such as the upper part of the
track and the lower part of the track so
your throat your sinuses and anything
that could lead to pneumonia plus it can
help Target GI infections and urinary
and tract infections so now let's talk
about the medications that are part of
the macrolide family and to help us do
that we're going to remember the word
face so F is for fedaxomycin and this is
actually new to the group and it's used
in cases of C diff and C diff is like
the super infection that invades the gut
that causes perfuse diarrhea and
unfortunately C diff is from prolonged
usage of certain antibiotics then we
have
azithromycin
Clarithromycin and erythromycin and
notice that these last three which have
been in the group for a really long time
end in thromycin so we have the row here
and we're dealing with Mac row line so
hopefully that can help you remember
that for whenever you're looking at your
patient's Med and saying oh this is a
macroli now how can you expect to
administer these to a patient well
they're absorbed fairly well in the gut
so we can give them orally or we can
give them in severe cases parenteral
namely the IV route now let's talk about
how macrolides work so these medications
generally have a bacteriostatic effect
on the bacteria meaning that they stop
the growth and reproduction of the
bacteria now depending on the antibiotic
group it'll work differently for
instance like aminoglycosides that we
talked about in our previous lecture
they have a bacterial subtle effect on
the bacteria meaning that they kill them
but generally speaking macrolides affect
how they are able to grow and reproduce
now how they do this is that they
inhibit the protein synthesis of that
bacteria so we're talking about the
creation of proteins now proteins are a
very important structure for the
bacteria they need healthy proteins that
are able to function correctly in order
to survive and thrive but that's the
exact opposite of what we want whenever
we're dealing with a bacterial infection
so if we can somehow stop or inhibit
this process of creating proteins we can
get rid of this bacteria so what we want
to do is we want to Target the structure
in the bacteria that creates the
proteins and that is the ribosome so the
ribosome is a really neat structure it's
made up of a large subunit known as 50s
and a smaller subunit known as 30s and
these two subunits come together to
stack amino acids and it creates this
beautiful polypeptide chain hence our
protein now the macrolides can help
affect this process and what it does is
it'll Target the big part of the
ribosome 50s so remember that macro
slides macro means big it targets the
bigger subunit of the ribosome which is
known as 50s the number 50 is larger
than 30. so remember that it goes here
and whenever it Targets this subunit
what it's going to do is it's going to
affect translocation so we're going to
inhibit how messenger RNA and transfer
RNA can move within this ribosome to
create the protein so whenever we do
that we affect the growth and
reproduction of our bacteria and that's
what we want to do we want to get rid of
this infection now let's talk about our
role as a nurse whenever we're
administering these medications so
before Administration you just want to
confirm that your patient isn't allergic
to these medications now sometimes when
a rotation is allergic to let's say
penicillin the macrolides may be a safer
alternative for them also look over your
orders make sure you don't need to
collect any cultures before starting the
medication now during Administration you
want to make sure that you are
monitoring for the effectiveness of this
medication is it actually working to
treat the infection so what are some
things that tells you this medication
isn't working your patient's getting
worse and they may need something else
well you want to make sure that your
patient doesn't have abnormal body
temperature where it's like way too high
or way too low their blood pressure is
hypotensive they're a tachycardic
they're having difficulty breathing
they're having mental status changes and
their white blood cell count is severely
elevated remember a normal count is
about five to ten thousand so anything
greater than that is a warning sign now
another thing you're going to be doing
as a nurse is you're going to be
monitoring for adverse effects that
could happen with this group of drugs
plus you want to be able to educate your
patient about it so they can let you
know hey this is happening so to help us
remember those adverse effects so we're
going to remember the word clog C is for
cardiac issues specifically a prolonged
QT interval which could lead to a dead
deadly Rhythm known as torsods the plant
and there is an increased risk of this
happening if your patient's also taking
other medications on top of taking this
antibiotic like some antiarrhythmics
like amiodarone or quinidine or if
they're on quinolones that can do that
or like Haldol which is an antipsychotic
L is for liver problems like cholestatic
jaundice which tends to happen with
erythromycin which is the oldest one of
this group of medications so you'd want
to monitor those liver enzymes look at
the alt the AST the bilirubin level and
then just look at the patient are they
experiencing jaundice are they having
abdominal pain they're really fatigued
they have dark colored urine and light
colored stool the dark colored urine is
where the bilirubin is spilling over
into the kidneys and instead it should
be in the stool so it's taken the color
away from the stool so the stool looks
light in color instead of the nice dark
brown color O is for ototoxicity so this
is a toxicity that's a affecting the ear
specifically those hearing structures of
the ears and it tends to be reversible
so you want to tell your patient to
immediately report any ringing in the
ears hearing loss they're feeling dizzy
or just feels full in their ears now
this tends to happen in patients who are
taking high doses of these medications
and who also have altered renal function
and then lastly is G for GI upset now
this tends to happen because of
increased GI motility that can happen
with erythromycin so some patients who
are taking erythromycin they report that
it's causing them a lot of GI upset so
if it is happening and they can't
tolerate it you can tell them it's okay
to take it with some food because that
may help decrease it but as a side note
it's best to take this group of
medications without food because it
helps encourage High absorption of the
medication so if GI upset isn't
happening you want to educate the
patient to take this medication group
one hour before or two hours after a
meal with water only about 8 8 ounces of
water and not to drink it with any
acidic drink like fruit juice or milk
because that can actually alter the
absorption okay so that wraps up this
review over macrolides and if you'd like
to watch more videos in this series you
can access the link in the YouTube
description below